Laurent fabieux c'est l'invité de preuve
par 3 bononsoir Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ravi d'être avec vous merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
aussi bien sûr faites campagne dans
cette entre deux tours d'une primaire
qui pourrait d'ailleurs se révéler
périlleuse pour le Parti socialiste
enquête de leadership depuis des années
oui si le aa été trop serré je ne sais
pas si vous avez un pronostic écoutez
moi j'ai un souhait c'est que Martine
auri soit désigné et soit président de
la République mais il semble que ce soit
probablement très très serré très serré
de toutes les manières quel que soit le
titulaire de la victoire il y aura un
rassemblement et on y verra et des
personnes comme moi y veillont alors en
tous les cas vous l'avez rappelé vous
êtes soutien de Martine auri dans cette
compétition la plus compatible à vos
yeux avec les idées sinon avec la
personne hein d'Arnaud mondebourg vous
serez Inter Rogé dans un instant par
Christine Pouget de l'Agence France
Presse notre partenaire et puis par
perine tarnaau de Public Sénat Nicolas
Sarkozi critique la primaire socialiste
il la juge contraire à l'esprit de la 5e
République et qui ne peut-être l'otage
dit-il des partis est-ce qu'il a raison
sur le fond non euh et je vais vous
donner l'explication parce que vous êtes
certainement à temp pourquoi est-ce que
Monsieur Sarkozi prend cette position
qui est d'ailleurs contredite par son
premier ministre monsieur Fillon qui a
trouvé que les primaires étaient
excellentes par le président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est du même
parti monsieur accoyet alors pourquoi
pourquoi Monsieur Sarkozi prend-il cette
position et bien je vais vous faire
cette révélation c'est parce que s'il y
avait des primaires au sein de l'UMP il
ne serait pas désigné pour être candidat
et voilà pourquoi il prend cette
position bien mais c'est vrai qu' a
priori on ne peut pas imaginer des prima
dans un parti dont est issu le président
sortant ça vous le reconnaissez aussi ça
concerne pas directement oui mais enfin
la réalité si vous voulez c'est que cont
de la politique qu'il mène monsieur
Sarkozi est devenu très impopulaire et
que au-delà de cette impopularité la
majorité des Français y compris à droite
ne souhaite pas qu'il se
représente et donc il essaye de de de
noyer le poisson si on peut dire et puis
la réalité aussi c'est que les primaires
peut-être on va en parler ont été
jusqu'ici un très très grand succès et
que la droite au lieu de reconnaître ce
succès bon simplement en disant bah
c'est une bonne idée on fera la même
chose essaie de s'accrocher aux branches
on avait déjà eu je ne sais pas si c'est
Monsieur Copé monsieur Guan ou d'autres
ou les tous les deux qui nous avaient
expliqué que c'était attentatoire à la
démocratie qu' allit avoir des fichages
et cetera évidemment tout ça n'avait
aucun sens et l'autre jour je je
m'exprimais à la télévision avec
Monsieur Copé en face de moi je l'ai
remercié parce que je lui ai dit il s'y
attendait pas que il avait contribué à
succès en critiquant de manière
tellement absurde ce système
que finalement les gens avaient été
intéressés non c'est n un grand succès
c'est une démocratisation de la
démocratie ça va changer beaucoup de
choses et je crois que c'était le moment
de le faire et il faut reconnaître vous
ctiez Arna mondbourg Arnaud monondbour
était un des promoteurs de de cette
affaire et martineri l'a décidé l'a
organisé et c'est un succès très bien
les mérites leur reviennent à tous les
deux donc
martinbour il sera beaucoup question de
ce nouveau couple au cours de cette
émission évidment Laur Fabius vous avez
cité effectivement cette forme de
cacophonie dans la majorité vous avez
cité Bernard accoyet également François
Fillon qui juge effectivement que bah
les primaires sont un processus moderne
est-ce qu'il y a une nouvelle ligne de
fracture dans la majorité ou dans le
sarcosisme aujourd'hui pas le mieux
placé pour en juger mais je crois que
moi j'ai vu ça puisque j'étais à
l'Assemblée nationale cet après-midi on
discutter avec des collègues de droite
et beaucoup d'entre eux disent que tôt
ou tard euh ils seront amenés à à y
venir donc pour vous en tous les cas sur
les primaires l'analyse de François
Fignon est la bonne c'est la même que
que la votre est-ce que le premier
ministre dit vrai quand il dit
qu'actuellement sous le poids des 17 %
d'Arnaud Montebourg au premier tour il y
a une surenchère à gauche ben il est
très très aimable de s'intéresser à nous
euh ça doit lui faire un dérivatif pour
ses propres problèmes mais à dépend qui
sont ceux de la France qui sont ceux de
la France oui enfin il y a ceux de la
France qui sont très lourds on va en
parler et puis ce de son propre camp non
je je je crois que le le problème ne se
pose pas en terme de surenchère
euh le résultat des primaires il faut le
rappeler bon François Hollande est
arrivé en tête moins que ce qu'il
espérait enfin en tête martine aubré a
fait un excellent score Arnaud bonbourg
a été une surprise puisqu'on pensait
qu'il serait à jeu avec seses Royal et
puis il a fait nettement plus et alors
du coup Arnaud a fait valoir je crois
qu'il doit envoyer une lettre ses
propositions mais enfin elles sont
connues et en ce qui concerne Martin
auri euh le le le le fait que c'est que
les électeurs de d'arneauondbour se
retrouve dans la ligne de martinourri ne
pose pas de problème elle n'a pas changé
de ligne puisque sur quelques points
auquel tient Arnaud mondbourg
c'est-à-dire le fait que l'Europe doit
être à la fois offensive et défensive le
fait que les banques doivent être
beaucoup mieux contrôl le fait que il
faut moderniser notre système
institutionnel le fait qu'il faut lutter
contre contre toutes les formes de
corruption ce sont des thèmes dans
lesquels non seulement nous nous
reconnaissons mais que nous avons mis en
avant donc ça ne pose pas de problème on
va en parler plus longuement dans un
instant mais quand Nicolas Sarkozi
aujourd'hui en déplacement dans la
Creuse tient un véritable discours de
candidat hein et dénonce un déchaînement
de démagogie venant de la gauche
aujourd'hui il met notamment en avant le
thème de la démondialisation cher Arnaud
mondtebourg il met en avant les
critiques contre la casse des services
publics aussi en milieu rural et il
voità globalement il dénonce un
échaînement de démagogie oui mais ça je
je ne pense que ça marchera pas parce
que la
gauche telle qu'elle se présente dans
cette élection est et sera sérieuse bon
moi je prends mon propre cas si on
voulait me faire passer pour quelqu'un
d'incapable de gérer le pays c'est raté
donc il faut trouver un équilibre bien
sûr il faut être la fois très sérieux
notamment sur les finances publiques les
déficits qui sont énormes et en même
temps redonner un dynamisme mais
l'argument de démagogie ça ne
fonctionnera pas non le problème de
Monsieur Sarkozi c'est que bon il est en
campagne depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs ça n'étonne personne mais sa
difficulté c'est quoi c'est que comme la
situation est mauvaise et qu'il est
président de la République et qu'il y a
un rapport entre les deux même si la
crise explique pour une part les choses
ou
bien il ne propose rien de nouveau et
dans ce cas-là on lui dit mais monsieur
comme vous avez obtenu de mauvais
résultat ça sert à rien que vous
représentiez ou bien il propose des
choses nouvelles peut-être le ferat-il
mais à ce momentl il dit mais c'est très
bien mais pourquoi ne l'avez-vous pas
fait et il aura beaucoup de mal à sortir
de ça h alors vous dites que le score
sera certainement serré dimanche est-ce
que vous CZ la primaire ouai bien sûr
dimanche soir oui écoutez je je ne sais
pas quel il sera mais est-ce qu'on
connaîtra le résultat d'ailleurs dès
dimanche soir parce qu'on voit que c'est
très difficile de compter les bulletins
oui c'est difficile parce que c'est ce
sont les les militants socialistes même
qui ont organisé tout là vous l'avez vu
d'illeurs il y avait une atmosphère qui
était très particulière dans les bureaux
de vote je sais pas si vous avez
l'occasion de de d'y passer il y avait à
la fois beaucoup de solennité hein c'est
un un vrai vote et en même temps une
joie une convivialité c'est c'est c'est
très c'est très particulier et là il
faut du temps pour faire remonter les
bulletins il faut en même temps isoler
les listes électorale et faire contrôler
par viissier enfin on a pris vraiment
beaucoup de précaution puis je crois
qu'il y a une panne de de telle ou telle
machine
mais je pense que pour le deuxème tour
nous n'aurons pas ces problèmes en tout
cas j'espère en tous les cas Martin auri
très vite a dit qu'elle avait beaucoup
de points de convergence avec Arnaud
mondtebourg mais ce dernier n'a cessé de
répéter pendant toute sa campagne que
finalement il y avait une grande
proximité entre Martine aub et François
Hollande lui ne fait pas véritablement
la la différence c'est ce que j'ai lu
effectivement c'est ce que j'ai lu alors
il y en a une pour vous quiferit plus
pencher les électeurs d'Arnaud
Montebourg sur votre favorite écoutez
moi je je les connais tous évidemment
très bien depuis longtemps
euh bon je je pense que beaucoup
d'électeurs de d'Arnaud gondebourg euh
on sont prononcé pour pour lui parce
qu'ils avaient le sentiment qu'il avait
une ligne disons de gauche pour pour
parler simplement de protestation et de
changement fort par rapport à l'existant
bon c'est la ligne aussi de de martinri
alors il peut y avoir des différences
sur tel ou tel point mais je trouve que
ces électeurs-ci qui il sont
parfaitement libres d'ailleurs Arnaud
l'a dit bon personne n'est propriétaire
de ces voix se retrouveront plus
facilement de ce côté-là pour vous ce
n'est pas rosebonnet et bony rose au
briolande écoutez il il y a beaucoup de
il y a beaucoup de de il y a beaucoup
heureusement de points communs puisque
mais quand même il y en a il y a une
plus de il a des différen de comment
dire de de tempérament d'expérience de
caractère et euh une gauche molle du
côté de François Hollande non je dirais
que euh fr fr Hollande euh comment dire
il a une position de de centriste de
gauche bon et et martinopr a une
position centrale à gauche c'estàdire
qu'elle est par sa position capable de
rassembler les socialistes bien sûr ce
qu'elle fait à la tête du Parti
socialiste les non socialistes
communistes et autres radicaux les
écologistes et puis après il faudra
rassembler les Français donc c'est c'est
C élément de position centrale qui est
important quand on veut être candidate
alors donc j'écoute vos arguments Laur
Fabius donc je vous écoute pour vous il
serait inv vraisemblable car NAS
Montebourg par exemple disent je vote
Hollande je je nen sais rien je sais pas
selon votre analyse ça vous paraît
invraisemblable écoutez je peux pas me
prononcer à la place d'Ar bondbourg qui
est un homme de talent et qui fera ce
qu'il entendra faire bon simplement je
crois qu'il y a une logique pour ses
électeurs alors vous dites centre gauche
pour François Hollande mais je note
quand même que Martine Aubri administre
la ville de Lille avec des élus du
modème al c'est tout à fait exact qui
ont pris parti pour son projet d'accord
bien tout le monde fait des risettes
évidemment Arnaud Montebourg depuis
dimanche soir franchement Laur Fabius
vous refusez de voir cette forme quand
même de condescendance qu'il exprime
vis-à-vis de son parti il a dit j'ai
sorti le PS du fourmol
oui le formol c'est c'est liquide là oui
oui c'est liquide oui oui écoutez Chac
chacun a ses
comparaisons mais bon voilà de
commentaire pas de commentairire vous
vous préférez ignorer son pouvoir de
nuisance aujourd'hui non c'est pas du
tout en ces TER nous avons de très
bonnes relations personnelles il y a pas
et pour reprendre votre comparaison il
n'y a pas de cadavre dans le placard
d'accord est-ce qu'il apporte des idées
nouvelles vraiment Arna Montebourg euh
il a de la fougue du talent euh et il
met l'accent sur des choses en les
faisant ressortir des éléments que
nous-mêm développons et parfois depuis
longtemps mais plus on a de talent
rassemblé mieux c'est je prends un
exemple en faisant référence à ce qui
s'est passé il y a quelques années vous
rappelez le traité constitutionnel
européen tout le débat qui avait eu lieu
bon là ça vous fait un point commun vous
êtes le seul d'ailleurs dans ce cas-là
parmi les enfin les autres compétiteurs
avaient tous voté oui là vous aviez un
point d'accord avec Arna mondbour oui
mais Martine Aubri dont nous parlions a
réuni autour d'elle des gens qui ont
voté oui des gens qui ont voté non bon
et je me rappelle que l'un des thème que
j'abordais c'était que oui je suis
fondamentalement pro-européen mais
l'Europe doit être à la fois offensive
et défensive et nous proposons déjà à
l'époque de modifier le rôle de la
Banque centrale européenne de faire en
sorte que les chinois ne puissent pas
faire tout ce qu'il voulaent sans que
nous nous puissions aussi intervenir
chez eux le fait que j'étais contre les
délocalisations ce sont des thèmes qu'on
retrouve et c'est très bien alors avant
d'accueillir Christine Pouget de
l'Agence France Presse donc on va voir
concrètement ce que demande aujourd'hui
Arnaud monondtebour aux deux finalistes
les deux impétrants comme il dit on voit
ça tout de suite avec margaot
auriot c'est une lettre qui est
désormais au centre de toutes les
attentions une lettre adressée par
Arnaud mondbourg au de candidat avec une
question qui intégrera le mieux ces
quatre conditions le protectionn
européen la mise sous tutelle des
banques l'avènement d'une 6e République
et la lutte contre la corruption avec
ces 17 % de voix Arna mbourg le sa il
est désormais l'arbitre du second tour
des primaires Martine auri ou François
Hollande à la première il ne pardonne
pas laffire Guerini le second avait
rejeté son concept de 6e République pour
moi ce sont les deux faces d'une même
pièce Martine aub François Hollande je
l'ai dit dans la campagne sont les
héritiers du même tradition politique
ils ont le même projet d'ailleurs
Martine Aubri elle-même a déclaré
qu'elle n'avait pas de différence de
projet avec François Hollande elle
n'avait que des différences de
tempérament je ne crois pas qu'on
dérange des millions d'électeurs pour
des querelles de tempérament l'équation
est délicate mais Arnaud mondebourg fera
son choix hier il avait entretenu le
doute aujourd'hui le député de sonéloire
l'a décidé je prendrai mes
responsabilités ça va rien dire bah si
ça veut dire que je suis un dirigeant
politique je suis capable moi-même de
faire des choix et donc je ferai
certainement un choix sa voix il
l'amonille maintenant au prix fort il
réclame au candidat un engagement écrit
il publiera même leur réponse entre
séduction et refus de se laisser
manipuler Martine Aubri et François
Hollande eux n'accepteront pas toutes
ces exigences je ne suis pas ARN je suis
François ça vous a pas échappé Sion vous
auriez été victime d'une illusion je ne
vais pas reprendre le projet des autres
c'est quand Mme comble que celui qui a
fait près de 40 % finisse par prendre le
projet de ceux qui ont fait beaucoup
moins reste à savoir si Arnaud mondbour
se prononcera à titre personnel ou s'il
appellera ses électeurs à le suivre
réponse dans la semaine après le débat
de l'entre de tour des primaires
socialistes voilà et donc Christine
Pouget nous a rejoint de l'Agence France
Presse Christine bonsoir bonsoir l
Fabius alors on vient de voir Arnaud
mondbourg vous dites que vous avez très
bonne relation avec Arnaud mondbourg qu'
a pas de cadavre dans le placard
mais enfin on a un peu l'impression que
les deux finalistes sont un peu les
otages d'Arnaud bondbourg qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je crois pas je crois pas
en tout cas je peux parler pour ce qui
concerne la personité que je soutiens
qui qui Martine auri non et les
convverggences sont faciles et et
naturels bon mais on a beaucoup parlé de
cela c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai ça tout tourne autour de lui
oui mais
comme plus non oui mais comme nous
l'avons souligné les uns et les autres
bon Arnaud a fait un très bon score mais
en même temps il reconnaît lui-même que
les électrices et électeurs feront ce ce
qu'ils souhaitent de ce point de vue-là
je je veux faire un pronostic vous me
disiez quel est votre pronostic je pense
qu'il y aura au deuxème tour pas mal de
gens qui n'étaient pas aller voter au
premier tour et réciproquement peut-être
des gens qui étaient allés au premier
tour qui n'iront pas au deuxème et
notamment des personnes qui ne sont pas
socialistes euh et qui d'habitude ne
vote pas socialiste mais qui vote à
gauche bon parce ce que ces personnesl
se rend se rendent compte de plus en
plus que pour la première fois ils ont
la possibilité de elles ont la
possibilité ces personnes de choisir
pour qui elles vont voter au deuxème
tour bon d'habitude bon admettez vous
êtes écologiste ou vous êtes Front de
Gauche ou vous êtes bon en tout cas vous
n'êtes pas socialiste vous votez pas
socialiste au premier tour mais au
deuxième tour comme le socialiste en
tête vous devez voter pour lui ou pour
elle mais vous navez pas choisi cette
fois-ci ces personnes qui peuvent être
des centaines de mil
vont dire voilà pour qui au deuxème tour
je vais voter et je pense que on ne
s'est pas encore rendu compte de cela et
ça peut faire vous l une sorte d'appel
non mais c'est c'est le sens parce qu'on
est en finale si vous voulez là la
personnalité qui sera
désignée sera vraisemblablement opposé à
Nicolas Sarkozy et vraisemblablement
présidente de la République donc on peut
choisir qui sait mais vous pensez par
exemple que les électeurs de ségolen
royale pourrai venir au deuxème tour
voter malgré tout vous pensez qu'il vont
il s'est pas trop attaché à la personne
de Segolen Royal vous pensez que ça
attachement à sa personne mais il y a
aussi un projet politique de ce point de
vue-là si je peux me permettre j'ai
trouvé que le le la façon dont C royale
a été traité y compris d'ailleurs par un
certain nombre de responsables socialist
n'était pas correct euh C Royal a fait
une campagne que j'ai trouvé très
courageuse et et et de qualité euh et
puis pour différentes raisons elle n'a
pas obtenu le résultat que d'ailleurs
les sond je lui prédisais là les
sondages se sont trompés he
et moi je mon pronostic c'est que c'est
royal reondira et donc en plus une femme
en difficulté c'est pas le enfin que ce
soit de de l'élégance de la courtoisie
ou de il faut pas il faut pas traiter
les gens comme ça et donc moi je je
trouve que elle rebondiraù est-ce que
vous la voyez demain quel rôle peut-elle
jouer
elle jouera un rôle dans la République
assurément vous l'avez appelé vous lui
avez manifesté un soutien euh oui je lui
ai dit un certain nombre de choses de
manière directe ou indirecte et je je
vous dis ce que je pense h alors il y a
un sondage qui vient de tomber opinion
noué et qui donne 54 % pour Hollande et
46 pour Aubri chez les sympathisants de
gauche est-ce que ça vous inquiète ou
est-ce que vous êt et le précédent
donnait combien il était un peu moins
favorable pour François Hollande oui
donnait 4 points de plus dans un cas et
qure points de moins dans l'autre ou euh
je ne sais pas quels sont les résultats
euh il faut être très prudent parce que
personne ne les connaît Martin refait un
peu son retard oui oui nettement euh je
je pense que
euh et ce n'est pas de l'intoxication ce
que je vous dis parce que j'essaie
d'avoir un sentiment une intuition euh
martinori est comme on dit dans d'autres
cerclle sur la montante hm hm vous
voulez dire qu'elle est elle est
combative qu'elle est euh oui etelle
elle est dans dans elle elle habite la
fonction elle habite le rôle sans être
arrogante parce que sans être
présomptueuse bon personne vous trouvez
qu'elle ne l'habitait pas avant je
trouve que plus la campagne se déroule
euh
plus quand on la voit quand on l'entend
on se dit elle ferait une excellente
présidente madame de la République et
vous aussi Michel parce que ça concerne
aussi les hommes bien sûr bien sûr ça
sera la président de tous les Français
tout sexe quand vous avez analysé les
résultats là de la primaire du premier
tour quelle est la géographie électorale
que vous pouvez en tirer est-ce que
c'est bien vrai que c'est Hollande qui
est plutôt l'homme des de la ruralité
j'ai pas regardé ça suffisamment
précisément donc je voudrais pas vous
dire de soutise
euh je peux vous
dire deux constats alors évidents que
j'ai
fait d'abord chez moi en Normandie
évidemment je connais très bien euh on
ne peut pas faire un découpage rural
urbain
euh si on faisait ce découpage là on se
tromperait bon en revanche par exemple à
Paris c'est vrai que Martin aubr a fait
un excellent score et François Hollande
moins bon
mais à Lyon aussi par exemple à Lyon
aussi
euh j'ai comme vous le savez une maison
dans laarriège je prenais donc
connaissance des résultats dans la riège
François Hollande est arrivé en tête
mais là où martinri était soutenu
vigoureusement par des élus elle est
arrivée en tête donc vous savez il y a
tellement
d'éléments qui peuvent jouer qui ont pu
jouer je ne ferai pas de je je ne suis
pas capable de faire une analyse
d'ensemble à ce stade al on a
l'impression quand même que au fil des
de de la semaine je veux dire le ton se
durcit beaucoup entre les deux
finalistes oh ça reste quand même très
policé écoutez policé policé Hollande
qui juge quand même que les critiques de
Madame auri à son égard sont insidieux
ce
matin au qui voilà exactement et qui a
parlé de oui mais vous savez si d'abord
il faut toujours rester très mesuré
c'est ma ma nature mon tempér un appel
un peu au CAL et il pas besoin ce sont
ce sont des des personnes très
responsables mais
euh je crois que les choses resteront
très mesurées en même temps il faut
débattre d'ailleurs c'est toute la
difficulté du débat qui a lieu mer c'est
que il faut à la fois discuter sans se
disputer donc c'est très très simple
sans se déchirer euh je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude et je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
pour l'issue et quelle que soit la
personne qui l'emportera il y aura un
rassemblement et c'est là où des
personnes comme moi pourront jouer un
rôle si c'était nécessaire mais je ne
crois pas
c'est-à-dire je je je pense que ça se
passera très bien spontanément mais quel
rôle vous pourriez être a euh si jamais
il y avait des
excès on pourrait être on pourrait être
amener à ce moment-là à à rappeler les
uns et les autres à la à la mesure mais
je pense que ce sera pas nécessaire vous
pensez vraiment oui oui oui ouiou et
même si le score est serré vous pensez
pas qu'il pourrait y avoir quand même
une crainte sur le parti qu'on vive un
peu un congrès de rince bis si le score
est très serré bah non je je crois pas
vous pensez que le parti ne sera pas
divisé en deux non de toutes les
manières si vous voulez si on veut euh
les les socialistes et beaucoup de
français en général ont envie que ça
change donc ils ont envie que la
personnalité socialiste gagne et euh on
sait que l'unité est absolument
indispensable donc voilà il faut que les
conditions de l'unité soit respecté non
je je n'ai pas d'inquiétude si euh par
malheur pour vous François Hollande
passit en tête vous avez eu des des mots
quand même assez peu amèes pour François
Hollande on souvient de votre petite
phrase à Bordeaux quand vous avez oui
enfin elle a été rapporté mais ce n'est
pas je ne l'ai pas prononcé donc parti
de C Président réuique on rêve de ces
phras qui de ces phras que ce n'est pas
mon style habituel vous le savez bien
donc voilà bon je connais très bien
François Holland je connais très bien
Martin au je connais très bien c'est ça
depu des Annand même avec lui on le sait
bien je veux dire depuis 2005 je ve dire
que ça s'est normalisé vos rapports avec
Hollande écoutez serile a j'ai mes
éléments de jugement puisque je je
connais bien les uns et les autres et
j'ai formé mon jugement et ce jugement
m'a conduit à soutenir très fortement
Martine aub alors il y a des divergences
de fond aujourd'hui concernant les le
programme notamment et les propositions
mis en avant par François Hollande je
pense notamment au recrutement à nouveau
de 60000 professeurs dans l'éducation
nationale il a chiffré cela lors du
débat du dernier débat à 2 milliards et
demi d'euros en expliquant bah c'est le
coût du du redoublement est-ce que vous
avez été satisfait par les explications
franis Hollande alors dites-nous
franchement vous savez en plus on m'a
confié la tâche que je
rempliraai je rendrai public pas public
que je donnerai au à la personnalité qui
aura été désignée au début novembre je
je je regarde la première année
l'application du projet mais cette
mesure là n'est pas dans le projet bon
euh il y a un aspect financier mais pas
seulement financier bon là-dessus Martin
une bonne formule que je prends
volontiers à mon compte et après je vous
parlerai finance il ne peut pas y avoir
d'embauche sans réforme et il ne peut
pas y avoir de réforme sans embauche bon
c'estàd qu'il faut prendre l'ensemble du
champ on a besoin de moyens dans
l'éducation nationale parce que les
coupes sombres ont été tellement fortes
que il faut bien sûr des moyens en même
temps ces moyens doivent être assortis
d'une discussion avec les organisations
syndicales qui le souhaitent qui le
demandent sur le fond alors le fond
c'est la pédagogie le fond c'est
l'organisation du travail le fond
c'est le salaire des enseignants le fond
c'est la présence enfin beaucoup
beaucoup de choses donc
euh il y aura certainement des embauches
mais je crois qu'il faut prendre
l'ensemble du problème euh dans sa
globalité alors maintenant sur l'aspect
proprement financier euh moi vous savez
j'été ministre du Budget puis ministre
des Finances donc je connais un petit
peu cela quand on DRIR regarder le
l'aspect financier il faut regarder pas
simplement le coût à la dernière année
mais le coût additionné bon alors si on
part de l'idée
que c'est
12000 fonctionnaires par an et que ce
type de fonctionnaire une fois chargé
coûte quelque chose comme 50000 € par an
vous pouvez faire le calcul quand vous
additionner pendant 5 ans ça vous fait
beaucoup 2 milliards plus que plus que
les 2 milliards et demi ah bah vous
pouvez faire le calcul mais faisons
attention
euh remarque plus général et puis ce ce
ce sera le mon mon mon indication euh
nous n'aurons pas beaucoup de marge de
malœuvre parce que les déficit qu'on
nous laisse sont colossaux la croissance
malheureusement risque d'être faible le
chômage augmente bon donc il faudra
avoir des priorités bon parmi ces
priorités il y a évidemment l'éducation
priorité très très forte euh mais il
faudra
donc toujours avoir à l'esprit que il y
a des embuches à faire je le répète mais
qu'il y a des changements qualitatif à
opérer et qu'il faudra associer les
partenaires sociaux voilà donc ça c'est
vrai pour l'éducation nationale mais
pour pour la sécurité sécurité c'est
vrai dans le domaine de l'emploi c'est
vrai dans beaucoup de de domaines pour
tous les salariés qui approche de l'âge
de la retraite aussi ah ça c'est un
autre sujet encore ça c'est un autre
sujet f là aussi oui oui oui oui bien
sûr les déficit là nous avons pris des
engagements et nous les avons chiffré et
dans les chiffres que moi-même j'intègre
j'ai intégré l'engagement collectif que
nous avons pris en ce qui concerne la
retraite par
exemple et et dans ce que disait
montebour là qui est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui vous paraîtrait
négociable ou pas négociable à savoir la
tutelle des banques qu'est-ce que serait
ben sur les
banques sur les banques euh ce que dit à
la fois arnaau mondbourg et c'est goen
royale parce que c'est un thème qu'elle
a beaucoup abordé me paraît intéressant
euh il y a quatre ou cinq thèmes sur
lesquels moi je me retrouve totalement
euh premièrement euh il me paraît
absolument nécessaire que euh il y ait
un euh un contrôle plus plus plus
sérieux des des activités bancair euh et
donc là ça passe à la fois par une
séparation entre les banques de dépôts
et les banques d'affaires parce que le
mélange finalement est très criticable
et ça passe dans certains cas par le
fait qu'il doit y avoir des
représentants de l'État au conseil
d'administration pour empêcher toute une
série DEES c'est un premier point un
deuxième point c'est que par exemple je
trouve pas normal que les banques
puissent avoir des filiales dans les
paradis fiscaux un troisième point c'est
qu'il faut créer une banque publique
d'investissement pour aider les PME un
4ème point c'est qu'il faut changer les
relations entre les usag consommateurs
et les banques c'est problème des agio
et un 5è point c'est qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une taxe sur les transactions
financières sur tous ces points nous
sommes en accord à la fois avec Colen et
avec voilà mais sur la
démondialisation alors ça c'est une
autre thématique on peut discuter sur le
thème si vous voulez sur le terme
excusez-moi sur le terme parce Martin
avait été très sé on peut discuter sur
le terme mais le fait que il faut
réguler la mondialisation et que
s'agissant de l'Europe il faut que
l'Europe je disais tout à l'heure
monsieur Gross soit à la fois offensive
mais aussi défensive ouverte mais pas
offerte exactement c'est une très juste
formule et c'est exactement ça et il
faut qu'il y a une vraie régulation de
la mondialisation ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui un mot à propos de la
banque Dexia vous avez mis en doute il y
a quelques jours le sauvetage de cet
établissement en disant ah là là si
l'État s'engage la France pourrait
mettre en péril son triple A ça n'est
pas ce qui se passe apparemment pour
l'instant Laurent Fabius et le
gouvernement veut all vite dans le
sauvetage de cette banque des
collectivités locales en France
particulièrement donc ça passe par son
démantellement et Laurent François
Fillon met en cause la gauche qui a
aussi pesé dans dans la gestion de cet
établissement plusurs questions est-ce
que vous voterez alors est-ce que vous
voterez ce sauvetage écoutez on va voir
exactement quel est le texte pour le
moment on n pas le texte mais c'est vrai
que à partir d'une banque qui était
consacré aux collectivités locales petit
à petit tel monsieur le tradc saisi par
la débauche cette banque a fait é
éormément de de choses et a été très
imprudente
B introduite sur le marché financier oui
mais les les imprudences ont été lié au
dirigeants de l'époque pas Michel Rocard
qui était le dirigeant de la banque
bononsabilité
partagé je je crois que il y a eu des
opérations très imprudentes qui ont été
faites bon en 2008 le gouvernement a
proposé un projet que N n'avons pas voté
derrière l'assemblée disant voilà la
solution pour sol de tout compte
moyenant quoi 3 ans après ça vient de
manière très négative bon il faut bien
faire quelque chose évidemment pour Tex
ça ce que j'ai dit je le maintiens non
j'ai je n'ai pas dit du tout que il y
aurait une conséquence automatique j'ai
dit faisons attention j'ai dit faisons
attention parce que il faut bien sûr
agir mais quand on agit en donnant des
garanties au bout du compte si les
garanties jouent évidemment il y a pas
besoin d'être un grand spécialiste pour
comprendre que ça a un effet sur notre
crédit et les Agen de notation on dit je
vais dans votre sens c'est pas tout à
fait il n'y a pas d'effet sur le
classement de la France actuellement oui
actuellement en tous les cas vous verrez
si vous voterez ce plan de sauvetage
dans quelques jours à l'Assemblée
nationale merci pas pas sans conditions
certainement condition vous allez
regarder donc merci une fois de plus
Christine on va voir maintenant avec T
tranui le sens de votre engagement
aujourd'hui Laurent Fabius on va aborder
à nouveau certaines
motivation sans doute en rapport avec
l'un des deux finalistes
ah on va voir ça c'est que tout cela
Laurent Fabius l'a décidé la
présidentielle ce n'est plus pour lui il
faut dire que l'ex-Premier ministre a
bien trébuché lors de la primaire de
2007 aujourd'hui il préfère rester en
retrait derrière Martine auri à qui il
apporte ses talents oratoires Laurent
Fabius est aussi un punias qui dans les
campagnes électorales il s'est trouvé
les formules et les angles qui font
mouch mais la majorité n'est pas la
seule à faire l'objet des attaques de sa
langue à serré il arrive aussi que
Laurent Fabius s'en prenne à certains
camarades du parti une de ces cible
préféré François Hollande il n'a jamais
considéré François Hollande comme
quelqu'un qui a des convictions vraiment
accrochées c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
toutes les petites phrases quand il dit
on n jamais vu un éléphant caché
derrière une fraise des bois disons que
François Hollande est une fraise des
bois François Hollande incarne la gauche
caoutchou et à Bordeaux Laurent Fabius
aurait déclaré François Hollande
Président on rêve derrière ces phrases
moqueuses existerait-il une Ranquine
plus tenace pour celui que Laurent
Fabius peine à considéré comme son égal
en 1984 François Hollande n'était que
conseiller occulte de l'Élysée alors que
Laurent Fabius était déjà Premier
ministre 20 ans plus tard en 2005 lors
du référendum sur la Constitution
européenne les escarmouches feutré se
sont transformé en guerre ouverte
aujourd'hui du côté de Martine nobri on
relativise ces attaques à dominem et je
pense pas que Laurent fabus soit
quelqu'un qui regarde la politique par
le petit bout de la lorniè à savoir les
petites phrases sur les uns et les
autres toujours est-il que Laurent
Fabius aurait du mal à jouer son rôle de
Sage actif auprès de François Hollande
si ce dernier l'emportait à la
présidentielle en revanche tout serait
différent si la mère de lîle se
retrouvait à l'Élysée alors on pourrait
imaginer un retour en grâce comme
récemment Alain Jupé au fond l'exemple
de d'Alain Jupé c'est un peu une petite
lumière pour lui c'est c'est un puissant
une puissante lumière qui lui permet de
se dire un retour est
possible voilà père interno est avec
nous pour ce dernier quart d'heure de
l'émission Laurent Fabius vous avez
raison de dire qu'il faut pas regarder
les choses par le petit bou on a
l'impression que Carl vous avez déjà un
petit peu rangé au placard alors que
c'est pas vrai la preuve la
multiplication de toutes vos
interventions médiatiques là depuis de J
c'est très aimable ce que dit
Monsieur non simplement pour pour à la
fois plaisenter être sérieux j'ai décidé
de ne pas être candidat à la présidence
de la République j'aurais très bien pu
être candidat et d'ailleurs beaucoup de
de ceux qui aujourd'hui soutiennent tel
ou tel des finalistes me le demander bon
mais ça c'est pour ma mémoire
personnelle mais simplement je je l'ai
décidé parce que j'estimais de pas être
en situation et je m'en félicite parce
que c'est là le petit trait d'humour
depuis que j'ai décidé de ne pas être
candidat à la président de la République
tous les dirigeants socialistes
m'adorent donc je suis très très content
de ça donc c'est bon pour les goû mais
est-ce que c'est le renoncement à cette
ambition présidentielle vous aé facile é
j'ai j'ai c'est c'est le hasard des des
des choses exercer toutes les fonctions
dans la République sauf êre sénateur
hein et sauf président de la République
oui oui mais ça pour cette fois-ci ça me
paraît compromis alors il va falloir que
je ratrape une ambition présidentielle
qui existe encore chez vous pour la su
clairement je veux que la gauche
gagne je pense queil faut changer
profondément les choses dans ce pays et
donc j'aiderai la personne qui qui qui
gagnera et à ce stade j'ai dit parce que
connaissant les uns et les autres
jugeant la difficulté des situations le
caractère la force les convictions les
projets que mon soutien allit à martinri
mais de toutes les manières je serais
quelqu'un de parfaitement loyal bon les
questions européennes et surtout
internationales étaient très très peu
présentes dans les débats du premier
tour de la primaire c'est quelque chose
ce que vous avez regretté oui euh d'une
certaine façon mais c'est un peu un
grand classique vous savez dans les
débats on les met toujours en 3e en 4è
partie et puis alors comme ça déborde ou
alors dans l'entre deux tours est-ce que
demain ces questions internationales
vont être elles sont prévues j'espère
queelles seront traitées parce que d'une
façon générale elles sont déterminantes
et surtout cette fois-ci puisque on est
évidemment très largement déterminé par
ce qui se passe en Europe et on a
beaucoup de choses à dire sur
l'Internationale sur la question
palestinienne sur l'Afrique noire sur la
question américaine sur des question qui
vous passionnent que que que j'aime
beaucoup oui et en plus je suis
quelqu'un qui qui voyage qui qui donne
des cours dans des universités
international donc ce sont des questions
que je suis mais je vous vois venir oui
on dit on dit on dit
on m gros sabot effectivement on dit que
vous aimeriez incarner ces questions
internationales dans un futur
gouvernement de gauche donc êre minist
du tout mais on PL la demande mais on en
est au stade peutêtre de plante souvent
avec un Jupé qui est d'ailleurs un très
bon ministre parce que à chaque fois que
lui ou moi sommes interrogés on dit mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas une
présidencef un duel entre Jupé Fabul et
nous faisons tous les deux la même
réponse le le nous estimons l'un l'autre
mais la calviciie n'est pas un élément
suffisant de classification politique
alors a la calvici on a vu dans dans le
petit sujet à l'instant que Carl mus
fait une analogie finalement entre vos
parcours entre votre parcours et celui
d'Alain Jupé vous reconnaissez vous
aussi des des similitudes Alain Jupé est
beaucoup plus âgé que moi un an de plus
un an de plus très exactement oui oui
ben écoutez c'est vrai que on a eu le le
le vraiment le l'énorme désavantages de
faire les mêmes études et puisavantag
prier min
oui oui oui mais enfin c'est quand même
un un grand honneur une grande chance et
après nos parcours étaient différents
nos choix sont différents mais il
n'empêche que c'est quelqu'un que
j'estime vous choisi tous les deux à
doubé par de grandes
personnalités très lourd très lourd
àorter le plus brillant d'entre nous
disait Jacques chir très l àorter parce
que vous savez j'avais lu une analyse
d'un philosophe assez intéressante sur
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un dauphin hein
et ce philosophe qui était en même temps
historien disait le le le Delphina
puisque c'est le nom ça ne marche jamais
parce que regarder son dauphin c'est
regarder sa propre mort oui et c'est pas
mal hein mais quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur la résurrection
politique et médiatique d'alin Jup sur
la résurrection je suis laïque
madame non mais sur le parcours actuel
d'Alain jupich n jamais été aussi
heureux je ne prononcerai pas euh
simplement je trouve en prant un peu de
distance que
euh depuis que il a pris ses fonctions
euh la politique étrangère de la France
est mieux tenu il avait eu sa tentation
de Venise à un moment à l'anjupé et vous
euh oui mais il y a longtemps je crois
et puis il a eu des épreuves et cetera
euh moi non moi le le le jour où je
décideraiis d'aller à venis girirer h la
politique étrangère est mieux tenu vous
pourriez rendre hommage également à
Nicolas Sarkozi oui maisess d'être un
agent assez explicite euh un agent de la
paix aujourd'hui on l'a vu en Libye oui
il y a dans dans autant en matière
économique et social je suis très
critique sur ce qu'a fait ou pas fait
monsieur Sarkozi en politique étrangère
il faut faire deux colonnes bon il y a
du positif et il y a du négatif
euh sur le négatif bon on sait le
discours de Dakar sur l'homme africain
qui est pas entré dans l'histoire le le
le le mauvaise analyse et comportements
sur la Tunisie enfin tout une ser t ch
les les zigzags sur la Chine bon côté
positif vous avez euh le comportement
nouveau et et positif en Libye bon
nouveau parce que on a quand même reçu
avant monsieur kadfi
euh une une certaine énergie euh montré
dans beaucoup de domaines simplement euh
l'histoire enfin la diplomatie il faut
avoir une vision longue et ce qui me
frappe c'est que Monsieur Sarkozi a
souvent une attitude qui sont plutôt des
des coups il fait des coups mais en
diplomatie c'est très dangereux parce
que vous retrouvez les mêmes partenaires
et donc si vous faites un coup une fois
en en prenant de de de biais un
partenaire après ça on vous le renvoie
négativement donc il manquait peut-être
au début après l'expérience est venue
une espèce de vision historique euh et
et ça alors Monsieur Sarkozi a de
l'énergie mais souvent on se dit mais
est-ce que cette énergie est bien
employée et souvent on répond non
aujourd'hui Laurent Fabius un accord a
été trouvé entre Matignon et les députés
de la majorité sur la taxe sur les hauts
revenus qui s'appliquera à partir de
250000 € est-ce que la charge de la
dette vous semble ainsi plus
équitablement répartie bah c'est une
petite contribution mais je crois que
les chiffres que j'ai vu c'est qu'on va
demander au Français les plus modestes
euh un milliard et quelques au titre de
la
taxe sur les mutueles de santé et on va
demander aux Français les plus fortunés
200 millions ce sera un peu plus
peut-être millions maintenant on leura
on leura redonné 1liard 800 millions
avec les modifications d'impôts sur la
fortune donc il y a 1 milillard 400
millions de différence au détriment du
budget de l'État est-ce que vous espérez
que le Sénat de gauche serve de vitrine
bien au Parti socialiste aujourd'hui
notamment en matière budgétaire parce
que c'est contex il y aura bien sûr une
une position importante du du Sénat de
majorité de gauche pour le budget mais
l'un des points sur lequels je
souhaiterais euh très modestement que le
Sénat et en particulier la majorité du
Sénat travaille c'est la préparation euh
du projet de
décentralisation parce que ça fait
partie de nos propositions c'est très
important le Sénat est la chambre des
collectivités locales je pense que nos
amis sénateurs sont magnifiquement
placés pour préparer vraiment ce que
doit être un nouvel acte de
décentralisation et moi je serai
d'autant plus sensible que comme je vous
le disais je travaille sur les projets
de loi que que nous devrons présenter a
déjà annoncé sa volonté de participer à
ce
decentralisation je compte beaucoup sur
le majorité droite à l'Assemblée
nationale il peut pas faire grand chose
Jere mais bien sûr peut pas faire passer
les projets mais les préparer vous savez
c'est très important quand on arrive
dans une nouveau cycle politique que les
projets soient prêts par des gens qui
s'y connaissent ce qui est le cas du
Sénat j'ai une dernière question qui n'i
rien à voir avec tout ça Laurent Fabius
l'Élysée se prépare à un heureux
événement est-ce qu'il sera strictement
privé ah ben ça je ne sais pas tout ce
que je peux dire mais je l'ai déjà
laissé entendre l'autre jour collègues
c'est que si cet événement a lieu comme
ça semble être le cas je souhaite à la
fois beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
bonheur à la famille et un très long
congé de
paternité à Monsieur SAR il annoncé
qu'il souhaitait pas vraiment en prendre
de congé oh ça peut-être différé
l'essentiel c'est qu'il soit long merci
Laurent Fabius d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est la fin de ce preuve
par 3 bonsoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine